so happy new year to you and your
families now i've been off a couple of
weeks
and after watching news over vacation
it's very evident it is transparent and
it is clear
that america is facing the biggest
informational crisis we've ever faced
we have a dually elected president of
the united states
that is just truly hated
by very powerful forces and they have a
united goal
they want to destroy the presidency and
this president
it is so bad that the president the
first lady can't even visit our brave
troops in iraq
or talk to kids about santa claus
without what is brutal character
assassination
personal attacks and just pure hatred
this is why we are introducing new
segments on this program
we're going to call them hannity watch
we're going to have a hannity watch
on media bias where we will expose all
the
hey trump news coverage there's going to
be a hannity watch on the economy
things and how they impact your family
your pocketbook
hannity watch on health care what is
best for your family
hannity watch on hollywood how they have
an agenda
that is both political and biased and
designed to indoctrinate
we'll have a hannity watch on campus
where political correctness and
indoctrination of our kids has gotten
way out of control
we'll have hannity watch on the deep
state prediction
huge stunning news this year
that will expose the biggest abuse of
power corruption
of our own government well i've had any
watch on socialism
that means the push to destroy free
market capitalism
had any watch on national security how
to protect our homeland
and efforts by some to undermine these
protections we'll have hannity on border
security
we'll be watching there as well as the
country needs to stop the flow of drugs
and human trafficking
and every night we're going to be asking
this question
is what we're talking about good for
america
is it good for you is it good for your
families
is it good for we the people now we plan
to expose
all the hatred that is out there every
day people that hate our constitution
people that would shred our bill of
rights first second fourth amendments
along the way we're going to offer
solutions to protect the interests of
every american this is not republican or
democrat
this is not conservative or liberal this
is about what is right for this great
country
so we begin that's my mission the
mission of this show going forward we
want to look out for you protect you
protect your family
fight daily to ensure this
constitutional republic
stays strong and vibrant for future
generations
and sadly that's at risk we have
powerful forces and you can see them
every day in society
that have now aligned to destroy the
president that we the people have
elected
it's a clear and present danger to every
american our constitution and our future
so we're inviting you each and every
week night at nine o'clock i can assure
you
and i promise you there'll be no other
show on television like this
and i hope you tell your friends and i
hope you'll join us all right tonight we
start
our hannity watch report on the hateful
forces that are determined to destroy
donald trump and his administration let
me be clear
they hate this president and they also
deep down
they hate we the people that voted for
him they can't believe we made that
decision
you don't believe me all right just
listen to long-serving democratic
congressman hank johnson
this just happened yesterday take a look
americans elected an authoritarian
anti-immigrant racist strong man
to the nation's highest office
donald trump and his make america great
again followers
who want to return america back to a
time when white men
and white privilege were unchallenged
and where minorities and women were in
their place
much like hitler took over the nazi
party
trump has taken over the republican
party
these types of ignorant hate-filled
analogies they're happening every day
and when they're not comparing us to
nazis well remember
we're the smelly walmart people as fbi
agent peter strzok called us or
the irredeemable deplorables that
hillary clinton
called us or remember when obama
referred to us
as the bitter angry americans that
actually cling to our god
our guns our bibles and our religion now
many of these forces are forces
of hate we know that many hate the
president
they hate we the people on this show we
are not going to be hating them back
instead every night on this program
we're going to be exposing them and what
is the corrosive politics of division
and this is what i call the five major
forces of hate you have the democratic
party
if donald trump cured cancer today and
gave every american millions of dollars
today everyone and they still try to try
to destroy this man
as he represents to them the biggest
obstacle
to them regaining power second perhaps
the most obvious haters in america
we have the hate trump media it's now on
tv
every newscast every second of every
minute of every
hour of every day a never-ending
non-stop trump hate fest it's on a loop
and newspapers in this country they're
actually trying to outdo each other
showing how much they hate trump the
most
now when has the media ever told you
about these things for example this is
what hannity watch is all about
what about the president's successes the
last two years what about the
accomplishments that are scrolling on
your screen that we're showing you
tonight night in and night out things
they never talk about
don't expect the mainstream media to
show this report
from real clear politics look at this
detailing the president's top 10
accomplishments of the year promises
made promises kept
his successful appointment he promised a
guy like brett kavanaugh
last year he got it done for the supreme
court or the squeeze on china
for unfair trade practices intellectual
property theft
that's changing the middle class wage
increase
the highest in 12 years the middle class
that the
democrats claim to care about the u.s
mexico canada trade deal
ending the iranian nuclear deal all
promises top accomplishments 2018
when he moved the u.s embassy to
jerusalem
smashing isis increasing jobs the lowest
numbers
unemployment numbers for minorities
keeping members of the migrant
caravan from pouring into the country
and we can't forget this is my favorite
america is now the largest oil
producing nation in the world not russia
not saudi arabia the united states of
america
and that doesn't include the pipelines
being complete that doesn't include
anwar
that's going to be millions of
high-paying career jobs for our fellow
americans
now third forces of hate the deep state
we already know hillary clinton
committed multi multiple felonies she
violated the espionage act
with top secret classified information
on a private server
we know she obstructed justice we know
she destroyed subpoenaed emails erased
hard drives broke up phones and
blackberries and iphones etc with a
hammer
we also know powerful people in the fbi
and the doj
purposefully rigged the investigation to
give her a pass that nobody else in
america would ever get
that is not good for america that's what
we're asking tonight
is it dangerous the answer is obvious
now all of this allowed hillary to
continue her pursuit of the presidency
remember they thought she should win 100
million to zero
and allowed her to funnel money into a
law firm hire an op research firm
hire a foreign national use dubious
russian
sources collusion to create a phony
debunked dossier on donald trump
well that's the collusion i guess they
were looking for but don't want to find
and we of course have the russian lies
never verified
never corroborated then disseminated
to you we the people before the 2016
election
to influence the outcome of that
election in her favor
and those same russian lies never
verified
were then used by top people in our
intelligence community
in the fbi and the justice department to
get
four fisa warrants to spy on a trump
campaign associate
both before and after the election all
signed off by top officials
here's a question tonight is that good
for america or is that dangerous for
america
when you have fraud perpetrated on fisa
court judges repeatedly
no arrests no report yet nobody held
accountable
the media ignores the biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal in modern
history
now if this is allowed to continue the
united states of america will become a
banana republic
we might as well shred the constitution
because it would be rendered meaningless
the principles of due process equal
justice under the law
equal application of our laws are
similarly
rendered meaningless the deep state has
been
in is out to destroy the president they
hate the president
and they're doing it by any means
necessary obviously and that's based on
what we know today and of course
item number four we have weak
republicans they hate the president they
only care about themselves
they stand for little they have no
courage we also have never trumpers
number five
they hate the president they just want
to say see we were right you were wrong
you non-intellectual blue-collar
hard-working
tax-paying law-abiding americans you did
this to us
no they're trying to undermine a free
and fair election
now imagine if any american tonight like
robert mueller
scrubbed the phones of trump haters
and russia investigators struck and page
clean
wipe them clean imagine if like james
comey
that you bragged about tricking a
33-year war hero into an fbi interview
by bypassing all normal protocol and
procedures
that would you that you would use in
past administrations
imagine the deputy fbi director telling
general flynn he didn't need a lawyer
and then charging him for lying now on
this show moving forward
we are looking to protect you protect
this great country
against forces of hate that would shred
our constitution
this will be your show we will be your
watchdog we plan to expose all of this
corruption
all of these lies all the double
standards when we see it
oh you mean like hypocrisy when
democrats supported building a wall and
don't any longer because trump wants one
we're going to expose that there really
is hate in america
real hate and that hate these aligned
forces
are trying to destroy the president they
hate the president and they hate us for
voting for him
they hate traditional core conservative
values
that we hold near and dear to our hearts
now i'll admit this one hour news
program to be very
blunt this show will be an island unto
itself
there will be no other show like it i
promise you we are dedicated to
protecting
these deeply held american values these
principles
we're dedicated to telling you the truth
about what's really happening in the
country
all right now we turn our hannity watch
on border security tonight
look at this a five-month-old boy
will never see his hero father again
newman california police officer legal
immigrant
ronald singh viciously murdered by an
illegal immigrant
with a very long criminal track record
and ties to violent gangs
now the county sheriff adam christensen
said that this horrific
crime could not have happened would have
been prevented
if not for california's catch and
release sanctuary city status
take a look i simply want to focus on
the fact that this is a criminal illegal
alien
with prior criminal activity that should
have been
reported to ice we were prohibited law
enforcement was prohibited
because of sanctuary laws and that
led to the encounter with officer singh
i'm suggesting that the outcome could
have been different
if law enforcement wasn't
restricted prohibited or had their hands
tied because of political interference
hands tied because of political
interference
sheriff christensen is going to be with
us tonight in just a moment
but it's very clear california's far
left lawmakers
they're not listening to the citizens in
their own state
we sent fox news contributor lawrence
jones to newman california to see what
californians
really think about that state's
sanctuary policies remember
they have criminals that should be
deported and handed over to ice
they set them free take a look
a lot of people are blaming the
california sanctuary state policy
do you agree with that i think it's the
worst thing california's done in a long
time
i'm not the big wall person yeah but i
think
a sanctuary state is crazy sanctuary
city policy
it's the stupidest thing that democrats
could have ever
done in this country we're going to show
you more of this later in the program
tonight but sadly
what happened in newman california is
all too common an occurrence over the
weekend a 22 year old man in knoxville
tennessee
killed by a suspected illegal immigrant
who swerved into
oncoming traffic just before christmas
three illegal immigrants
were indicted for the murder of a man
living in long island
so many lives have been senselessly lost
at the hands of people
who never should have ever been in this
country
ever on the federal level let me say
these statistics really slow so even
nancy pelosi
who doesn't want to fund a wall and
protect american
borders she can understand since
2014 51 murder convictions have been
handed down to illegal immigrants
228 federal assault sentences nearly 20
000
drug trafficking sentences on the state
level
it's even worse according to the gao and
their estimate since 1964
27 300 arrests
for murder have been carried out by
illegal immigrants over 120 000
sex offenses nearly 400 000 assault
charges
over a thousand acts of terror
here's a tough question and i want
people to fully understand this
if people keep getting killed
this five-month-old boy will never see
his father
his father the hero that got killed this
weekend
because we have people in custody we
know they're here
illegally they commit other crimes
we don't hand them over to ice we won't
enforce the law and
deport them well is congress going to
pay to raise the children of those
killed
like in the case of this california
officer will congress pay for the
children's
college education will they at least pay
for the funeral
because at some point they bear some of
the burden
because these failed government policies
are now aiding and abetting criminal
activity that otherwise would not happen
if we enforce the law if we protected
our borders
and nancy pelosi and her fellow
democrats they are now willing to
shut down the government to prevent even
a partial funding
of a border wall that protects people on
both sides now this wall is designed to
give border agents more time
to apprehend those that want to cross
illegally
i'll be the first to concede probably
the vast majority 99 percent
of people that want to cross into our
country they're looking for a better
life
for themselves their families their
children and an opportunity that they
don't have in their own country i don't
blame them
we have a right to know who is coming
into this country
we support legal immigration on new
year's eve
got 150 individuals there's the video
attempting to break across california's
border with mexico
again rocks other projectiles thrown at
border agents
and keep in mind those who successfully
cross our border illegally
on average if they get across criminal
justice system educational system
health care system it's costing we the
taxpayers around
70 thousand dollars per person
even top democrats a few years ago
realized the importance
of stemming the tide of illegal
immigration many of them sounded like
donald trump
take a look i voted
numerous times when i was a senator to
spend money
to build a uh a barrier
to try to prevent illegal immigrants
from coming in
and i do think you have to control your
borders
people who enter the united states
without our permission are illegal
aliens and illegal aliens should not be
treated the same as people who entered
the u.s legally
the american people will never accept
immigration reform
unless they truly believe that their
government is committed
to ending future illegal immigration
those who enter our country legally
and those who employ them disrespect
the rule of law and because we live in
an age where terrorists are challenging
our borders we cannot allow people to
pour into the u.s
undetected undocumented and unchecked
oh they sounded like trump but now
because trump wants it they don't want
it
make no mistake this battle is important
it's about saving lives
it's about stopping illegal immigration
and drug trafficking and human
trafficking the president must
stay strong on his promise get that wall
fully built they've started
but we got more to go i personally would
declare this a national security issue
and the commander-in-chief from my my
vantage point
he could allocate five billion dollars
from the military budget
and get the job done if the government
stays shut down
essential services don't let the media
scare you that continues
social security checks will go out the
coast guard is on duty
our military branches are on duty and
the people will be taken care of but the
cost of unfettered illegal immigration
is too high
the risks are too great how would you
feel
if you were a family member of this
young officer with a five-month-old son
killed this past weekend this is an
issue literally of life and death those
drugs
they're headed to small towns and big
cities all across america
so to my weak republican friends in
washington
hold the line have a backbone have a
spine
you're there to serve the american
people we must give our border agents
the tools they need
including the wall so they can end human
trafficking
drug trafficking violent criminals even
some terrorists or anybody else who
plans to break our laws and hurt
our fellow american citizens we support
legal
immigration on this program republican
democrat i don't care we're going to
call you
out especially republicans who don't
hold the line
and fund a border wall this is worth
fighting for and by the way the
president's promise that mexico pay for
the wall
well it's wasn't mexico ever going to
write a check
and we got a hannity flashback from then
candidate trump on the campaign trail
take a look
you don't expect he's going to write a
check but what you're saying is
that they will have to make concessions
well there's many different ways
so in other words you don't expect
mexico to say no yes mr trump here's a
check for 10 billion
it's not feasible it wouldn't look good
so you think the deals that you make
with it will more than compensate for
the wall
even if we tax them we may tax them okay
it doesn't make any difference
now that's a key reason the president
renegotiated our trade deal with mexico
we'll have more on this throughout the
show all right let's turn our attention
just briefly to mitt romney
um he's not been sworn in as senator and
romney is already launching a feckless
attack against the president
following his op-ed slamming president
trump for so-called character and
leadership issues
well the rnc chairwoman ronna mcdaniel
his niece tweeted well for an incoming
republican freshman senator
to attack president trump as their first
act feeds into what the democrats and
the media want
and is disappointing and unproductive
our friend the great one mark levine
issued an even
dire warning writing it's clear romney
will be a destructive force in the
senate
playing to the liberal media which will
praise him and seeking to create a
pathway to the presidency
and i'll add by the way um and i
supported mitt romney
that's the same media that brutalized
him
in 2012. it's sad that he has more
interest in closing up to those people
on the left that hated him than sticking
up for protecting
american citizens record low
unemployment american
energy independence securing our borders
issues he says he claims about
especially the
democrats continue to pursue this
radical left agenda
in 90 days you will know how left they
are